[Music]
honorable leadership is about living up
to duty when we're given a promotion and
put into a position of greater formal
leadership responsibilities that that is
often because we've done well at
something and our potential has been
positively evaluated so if you have a
set of different people and some of them
are seen as having greater potential
than others perhaps they've been more
accomplished than others then you would
expect them to be put into a position of
responsibility and leadership but if you
think about it that causes all of us to
see that promotion
as a reward not as a duty compare that
to a world where we see a promotion or
other kind of granting of leadership
responsibilities as a very solemn duty
that we have been asked to live up to
but we face leadership responsibilities
we're asked to do things that are
difficult we're asked to resolve
tensions that will require trade-offs
that will require that we make tough
decisions and whenever we do that we are
being challenged to live up to the duty
of our office there are exceptional
leaders who perhaps didn't go and take a
hundred percent market share and/or add
a billion dollars of revenue but day in
and day out were willing to confront and
deal with the most difficult situations
and I know right now you can think of
such leaders I challenge you to be such
a leader no leader is without
opportunity to grow
so where do you want to go explore
Stanford's upcoming programs
[Music]